am 20 mai wird in der wallenstein kassel
nehmen niederösterreichischen götzendorf
das 22 libanon kontingent in den
auslandseinsatz verabschiedet frieden zu
schaffen und frieden erhalten
das macht das österreichische bundesheer
seit jahrzehnten mit seinen
auslandseinsätzen die eine unglaublich
wichtige säule unserer
landesverteidigung sind die einen
bedeutenden beitrag zur österreichischen
sicherheits und außenpolitik
die 100 soldatinnen und soldaten des 22
kontingents kommen aus ganz österreich
ihre aufgaben im libanon sind vorwiegend
logistischer durch einen logistischen
einsatz werden sie die versorgung der
internationalen streitkräfte aus 40
nationen und mit immerhin rund 11.800
soldatinnen und soldaten und
zivilangestellten der vereinten nationen
sicherstellen sie tragen zu frieden und
ordnung im land bei und das wiederum wie
schon angesprochen sagt für mehr
stabilität in der region damit diese
probleme erst gar nicht nach europa
kommen im rahmen dieser verabschiedung
übergibt verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner ein fahnenband an den verein
österreichischer peacekeeper kurz vp als
sichtbares zeichen für die partnerschaft
die das bundesheer mit dem vp im
dezember des vorjahres eingegangen ist
abschließend wendet sich die
verteidigungsministerin noch einmal
direkt an die in den auslandseinsatz
gehenden soldatinnen und soldaten
abschließend möchte ich ihnen danken
jeder und jedem einzelnen von ihnen für
ihre bereitschaft für ihre
leistungsbereitschaft und ich darf ihnen
viel erfolg für diese mission wünschen
soldatenglück vereinbar
haben sie gesund
[Musik]